Back in 1994-- this is back in the days when people still delivered big news to each other by mail-- two women who barely knew each other, Martha Miller and Susan McDonald, got a letter from Martha's mom.
早在1994年——那是人们仍通过邮寄来传递重大新闻的年代——玛莎·米勒和苏珊·麦克唐纳这两位交情并不深的女性，收到了玛莎母亲寄来的一封信。
Dear Martha and Sue, have you ever suspected or been told that we took home the baby that belonged to Kay and Bob McDonald and they later took home the baby that belonged to us?
亲爱的玛莎和苏，你们是否曾怀疑或被告知，我们带回家的孩子其实是凯和鲍勃·麦克唐纳的，而他们带回去的那个才是我们的？
That's Martha reading. And the purpose of this letter is that Mrs. Miller is breaking the news-- 43 years after the fact-- to Martha and Sue that she took the wrong baby home from the hospital, that Martha and Sue were switched at birth, that she's not Martha's biological mom, she's Sue's.
这是玛莎在读信。这封信的目的，是米勒太太在事隔43年后向玛莎和苏坦白：她在医院抱错了孩子，玛莎和苏在出生时就被调换了，她并不是玛莎的亲生母亲，而是苏的。
And part of it what makes this so strange is that this wasn't the sort of thing where Mrs. Miller figured this to her surprise after decades of wondering and pondering and painstaking detective work. No, no, no. She knew it the day she got home from the hospital in 1951 that she had the wrong baby, a baby born to a woman named Kay McDonald. And she kept it quiet all those years.
这件事最离奇的地方在于，米勒太太并不是在经历了数十年的怀疑、推测和辛苦查证后才大吃一惊。完全不是。她早在1951年从医院回到家的那天就知道自己抱错了孩子，那是麦克唐纳太太生的孩子。但这些年来，她一直守口如瓶。
Here is how Mrs. Miller explained that in the letter. The other daughter in this baby switch, Sue, who was born to Mrs. Miller, the one writing the letter, but raised by Kay McDonald, the other woman, reads.
以下是米勒太太在信中对此的解释。苏是米勒太太亲生的，也是写这封信的人，但她被另一位女性凯·麦克唐纳抚养长大。现在由苏来读这段内容。
I had complete anesthesia, so was asleep when our baby was born. The nurse weighed the baby and must have left her in the delivery room until after Kay's baby was born very soon after mine.
当时我接受了全身麻醉，所以孩子出生时我睡着了。护士给婴儿称了重，肯定是在凯的孩子出生（就在我之后没多久）之前，把孩子留在了产房。
When we took our baby home, she sneezed five times in a row.
当我们带孩子回家时，她连续打了五个喷嚏。
Again, Martha Miller, who now goes by Marti, who once was the baby who sneezed five times in a row.
依然是玛莎·米勒（现在改名马蒂），她就是当年那个连续打了五个喷嚏的婴儿。
I thought that was strange. Never had that happened with any of our others. We had a baby scale at home. When I weighed the baby, she weighed two and 1/2 pounds less than her birth weight.
我觉得这很奇怪。我们其他的孩子从来没这样过。家里有婴儿秤，当我给孩子称重时，她比出生时的体重轻了两磅半。
I was sure then that there had been a mix-up. I talked to Norbert about it, but he did not want to disgrace our good Dr. Deslack. A week or so after the baby's birth, I was reaching for something way back in the attic closet and started to hemorrhage, then went into convulsions. Back to the hospital for several days and despair for my life. So I dropped the mixed-up baby pursuit.
那时我就确信抱错了。我和诺伯特商量过，但他不想让德斯拉克医生丢脸。孩子出生一周左右，我在阁楼壁橱深处拿东西时大出血，还出现了痉挛。我回到医院住了几天，当时绝望得以为自己要死了。所以我就没再追究抱错孩子的事。
As Martha grew, she did not look nor act like any other children. She was a delight to all of us, so pretty, so photogenic, so full of life. Our other children were very serious. Martha excelled in music, was a great cheerleader at school, very popular, and a blonde. Our other children had dark hair and all needed glasses for nearsightedness. Martha did not need glasses.
随着玛莎长大，她看起来和表现得都不像家里的其他孩子。她是我们所有人的开心果，长得漂亮，上镜，充满活力。我们其他的孩子都很严肃。玛莎在音乐方面很有天赋，在学校是出色的啦啦队长，很受欢迎，而且是金发。我们其他的孩子都是深色头发，而且都因为近视需要戴眼镜。玛莎不需要眼镜。
Finally, on July 10, 1994, Norbert was willing to go to Kay and Bob McDonald's 50th wedding anniversary celebration at Prairie du Chien United Methodist Church. When he saw you, Sue, he said, I don't need a DNA test. Sue is ours. She looks just like Mary Lydia. Would make a good twin to her. That is why I wanted to write this letter.
最后，在1994年7月10日，诺伯特愿意参加凯和鲍勃·麦克唐纳在草原杜辛联合卫理公会教堂举行的50周年结婚纪念日庆典。当他看到你时，苏，他说，我不需要DNA检测。苏是我们的孩子。她长得和玛丽·莉迪亚一模一样。她们俩简直是双胞胎。这就是我写这封信的原因。
So now we are both aware of what happened 43 years ago. We love you, Martha Jane-- I'm sorry. We love you, Martha Jane, as dearly as our other six children. I think you know that you will always be our daughter. But I thought each of you should know your biological and spiritual backgrounds. And know you have mixed feelings about this revelation. I have much anguish and many tears.
现在我们双方都知道了43年前发生的事。我们爱你，玛莎·简——对不起。我们像爱其他六个孩子一样深爱着你，玛莎·简。我想你知道你永远是我们的女儿。但我认为你们每个人都应该了解自己的生物学和精神背景。我知道你们对这个揭露可能会有复杂的情感。我内心非常痛苦，也流了很多眼泪。
But I feel I must get this out in the open, so you two know how wonderful that you both are Christians and great workers in the church. Do let me hear from you. I love you both. Thanks, and Jesus lead you in this time. Happy 43rd birthday to you, Sue.
但我感到必须把这件事公开，这样你们两个就知道，你们不仅是基督徒，还是教会里出色的工作者，这是多么美好的事。一定要给我回信。我爱你们两个。谢谢，愿耶稣在这一时刻指引你们。祝你43岁生日快乐，苏。
And to you, Martha.
也祝你生日快乐，玛莎。
Lovingly, your mom, Mary Kay Miller.
爱你们的母亲，玛丽·凯·米勒。
So at this point, you're probably wondering, why in the world didn't Mrs. Miller straighten this out quicker? Why did she listen to her husband back in 1951? Why the big concern about disgracing the doctor over, you know, having the wrong baby?
所以现在你可能在想，到底为什么米勒太太不早点把事情弄清楚？为什么她在1951年要听她丈夫的话？为什么非要担心因为抱错孩子而让医生丢脸？
And as you heard in the letter, one thing that makes this whole thing even stranger is that the two couples knew each other. The Millers were at the McDonalds' anniversary party. They have mutual acquaintances. They lived a short drive from each other's houses in Wauzeka and Prairie du Chien, Wisconsin.
正如你在信中所听到的，让整件事更奇怪的一点是，这两对夫妻彼此认识。米勒夫妇参加了麦克唐纳夫妇的周年纪念派对，他们有共同的朋友，住在威斯康星州沃泽卡和草原杜辛，距离很近。
And when Mrs. Miller finally let everybody know the truth, long after both girls were grown up with children of their own, it was disruptive. That is the kind of news nobody ever wants to hear. And when you get this kind of news as an adult, that your mom isn't really your mom or your daughter isn't really your daughter, and at the same time, you have a new mom or a new daughter, it is not so clear what you're supposed to do with this new parent or new child who's now in your life. What are you supposed to be with each other?
当米勒太太最终让所有人都知道真相时，两个女孩都已经长大成人并有了自己的孩子，这件事造成了破坏。这是没有人想听到的消息。当你作为一个成年人得知你的母亲不是你的亲生母亲，或者你的女儿不是你的亲生女儿，同时又突然有了一个新的母亲或新的女儿时，你根本不知道该如何面对生命中这个新出现的人。你们之间究竟该是什么关系？
And both Marti and Sue worried that the families they'd always thought were theirs would still want to keep them. And both mothers and daughters each had to figure it out on their own. All four women said things got very lonely for them.
马蒂和苏都担心她们一直以为属于自己的家庭会不再要她们。而这两对母亲和女儿都不得不独自去面对。这四位女性都说，那段时间她们感到非常孤独。
Today on our show, we hear what happens when somebody takes your family and throws it up in the air like a deck of cards. From WBEZ Chicago, it's "This American Life." I'm Ira Glass. We're devoting the full hour today to what happened to these two families. Jake Halpern is the reporter.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要听听当有人把你家庭像一副扑克牌一样打乱时会发生什么。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天将用整整一个小时的时间来讲述这两家人的遭遇。杰克·哈珀是我们的记者。
And before we start, just to help you keep everybody straight in this story, a quick overview of the two families. The Millers are the bespectacled, dark-haired ones from the letter. Mrs. Miller's husband, the Reverend Norbert Miller, was an evangelical preacher, devoted to the church. And they were a bookish, serious bunch. This was a house with a lot of rules. And there were a lot of kids too. Seven kids in all.
在开始之前，为了帮大家理清故事中的人物关系，先快速概括一下这两家人。米勒一家是信中提到的那些戴眼镜、深色头发的人。米勒太太的丈夫诺伯特·米勒牧师是一位福音派传教士，虔诚于教会。他们一家书卷气重，非常严肃，家里有很多规矩，孩子也多，总共七个。
The McDonalds are the light-haired ones from the letter. And it is a much smaller family, just two kids. And the feeling in their house was very different from the feeling in the Miller's house. They were easygoing quick to laugh and joke around. Mr. McDonald ran the TV repair shop in town. Here's Jake Halpern.
麦克唐纳一家是信中提到的浅色头发的人。这是一个小得多的家庭，只有两个孩子。他们家里的氛围和米勒家完全不同，他们随和、爱笑、爱开玩笑。麦克唐纳先生在镇上经营一家电视维修店。下面是杰克·哈珀。
It was the four women at the center of all this, the two moms and the two daughters, who were affected more than anyone. So let's take them one by one, starting with Sue, Mrs. Miller's baby, who was raised by the McDonalds.
正是处于这一切核心的四位女性——两位母亲和两位女儿——受到的影响最大。让我们一个一个来看，从苏开始，也就是米勒太太的孩子，由麦克唐纳夫妇抚养长大。
Before the letter arrived, the facts of Sue's life had seemed pretty orderly. She was a married mother of three living in Michigan, where her husband worked as a chemist. She was close to her mother. She called and visited her parents regularly. She also had an older brother, Bob, named after their dad. It was all pretty straightforward.
在那封信寄到之前，苏的生活看起来很有条理。她是一位有三个孩子的已婚母亲，住在密歇根州，丈夫是一名化学家。她和母亲很亲近，经常给父母打电话或去探望他们。她还有一个哥哥鲍勃，以他们父亲的名字命名。一切都很简单明了。
And yes, Sue was different from the rest of the family in certain ways, dark and tall and skinny in a family that was none of those. In a pretty lighthearted household, she was nervous, studious, serious. But that didn't seem so strange.
当然，苏在某些方面确实和家人不同：身材高大、皮肤黝黑、体态消瘦，而家人却并非如此。在一个轻松快乐的家庭里，她表现得紧张、好学且严肃。但这似乎并不奇怪。
In junior high, I remember my friend said to me, you must be adopted, because you do not look at all like your parents. And I said, I don't know. I asked my mother. I said, am I adopted? And she said, oh, no, no. She says, I was pregnant and you are my child. I wanted a baby, you know, and you're my baby. You were not adopted.
上初中时，我记得朋友对我说，你一定是领养的，因为你和你父母长得一点也不像。我说，我不知道。我问了我母亲，问我是不是领养的。她说，噢，不，不。她说，我当时怀孕了，你就是我的孩子。你知道，我想要个孩子，你就是我的宝贝。你不是领养的。
So that convinced you.
所以那番话让你相信了。
Oh, yeah. That was enough. I mean, that was right. My mom said, oh, well, you just take after great-grandpa this or aunt so-and-so. So then I just forgot about the whole thing.
噢，是的。这就足够了。我的意思是，那肯定是真的。我妈说，噢，你只是长得像曾祖父或哪位阿姨。所以我就把整件事忘了。
Years later when she got the letter that told her the truth, she was stunned. And she knew she had to break the news to the McDonalds, who'd raised her. But she didn't call them right away. Mr. McDonald had a bad heart and she didn't know what the stress would do to him. First, she wanted to be absolutely sure it was true. Blood tests were done with the Millers and they proved Mrs. Miller was right about the switch.
多年后，当她收到那封揭露真相的信时，她惊呆了。她知道必须把这个消息告诉抚养她长大的麦克唐纳夫妇，但她没有立即打电话。麦克唐纳先生有心脏病，她不知道这个打击会对他造成什么影响。起初，她想百分之百确定这是真的。后来他们和米勒一家进行了血液检测，证实了米勒太太关于调换孩子的说法是正确的。
Weeks went by and Sue began to fret. She wrote letters to her parents, but didn't send them. She worried her mother might reject her. Sue knew her mother had never been a big fan of the Millers ever since they met. And now, suddenly, it turned out Sue was one of them.
几周过去了，苏开始焦虑。她写信给父母，但没有寄出。她担心母亲可能会拒绝她。苏知道，自从两家认识以来，她母亲一直不太喜欢米勒一家。而现在，突然之间，结果显示苏竟是米勒家的人。
It was confusing. And then after I knew that I had been switched and that I had different genes, and my parents kept talking about these people that were so odd, the Millers, because Reverend Miller, he is an evangelical preacher. He wants people to know Jesus Christ and that they would be saved.
这让人困惑。我知道自己被调换了，基因也不同，而我的父母一直在谈论那些米勒家的人有多么古怪，因为诺伯特牧师是一位福音派传教士，他想要人们认识耶稣基督并获得救赎。
And I'm really like that too. Sometimes my mom thinks I'm a little fanatical. I'm really a Miller. What does she think of me? I mean, that's my biological family.
我也很像他。有时候我妈觉得我有点狂热。我真的是米勒家的孩子。她会怎么看我？我的意思是，那是我的生物学家庭。
So I did think, yeah, she's going to know that's not my daughter. And she's going to get this popular Marti, who's so fun-loving and looks like her. And then she's going to say, well, I don't need that daughter anymore. She's part of that odd family.
所以我确实想过，是的，她会知道那不是她的女儿。她会得到那个受欢迎的、开朗且长得像她的马蒂。然后她会说，好吧，我不再需要那个女儿了，她是那个古怪家庭的一部分。
A month after she got the letter, Sue went to see her biological mother and father. This is a videotape of that first meeting.
在收到信的一个月后，苏去见了她的亲生父母。这是一段那次首次见面的录像。
And who are these people?
这些人是谁？
Now, this-- you tell them who that is.
现在，这个——你告诉他们那是谁。
These are my--
这是我的——
Is this your dad?
这是你爸爸吗？
My dad.
我的爸爸。
Right there.
就在那儿。
Sue looks happy. Reverend Miller is affectionate with her, putting his arm around her waist. Everybody's smiling. Sue now had four new sisters and two new brothers. And the Millers show her pictures of her other relatives.
苏看起来很高兴。诺伯特牧师对她很亲热，搂着她的腰。每个人都在笑。苏现在有了四个新姐妹和两个新兄弟。米勒一家给她看她其他亲戚的照片。
He's a roustabout. He went to Oregon to get away from a-- he got a girl in trouble, see?
他是个流浪汉。他去俄勒冈是为了躲避——他惹了一个女孩怀孕，明白吗？
Oh.
噢。
There's a lot of nervous laughter and there are some awkward moments, like when Sue talks to Mrs. Miller about the fact that she never got enough breast milk as a baby.
席间有许多紧张的笑声和尴尬的时刻，比如当苏对米勒太太说她小时候从未获得足够的母乳喂养时。
My mother didn't have enough milk for me. It's all your fault. Did you have enough?
我母亲当时没有足够的奶水给我。这都是你的错。你当时有足够的奶水吗？
But overall, the Millers seem giddy that their daughter has finally come home. And Sue seems eager to know them.
但总的来说，米勒夫妇似乎很高兴他们的女儿终于回家了。而苏看起来也很渴望了解他们。
Esther. You look like her too.
埃丝特。你看起来也像她。
That's what I was thinking [INAUDIBLE].
我也是这么想的。
And you look so much like Carol.
你看起来非常像卡罗尔。
Later that same day, Sue drove to the McDonalds', to the parents she'd grown up with. After dinner, she sat down and told them about Mrs. Miller's letter, told them point-blank she wasn't their child. At first, they refused to believe her, but then she told them about the blood tests. Finally, Sue handed over all the letters that she hadn't sent them in the past month, letters telling them how much she loved them and how much she wanted to stay their daughter.
那天晚些时候，苏开车去麦克唐纳家，去找抚养她长大的父母。晚饭后，她坐下来，向他们讲述了米勒太太的信，直截了当地告诉他们，她不是他们的孩子。起初，他们拒绝相信，但后来她告诉了他们关于血液检测的事。最后，苏交出了过去一个月里她没敢寄出的那些信，信中表达了她多么爱他们，多么想继续做他们的女儿。
And like my dad said, you are my child. I changed your diaper. And my mother, nothing was going to be different between us. But it took a while for us to-- how are you going to think?
就像我爸说的，你就是我的孩子，我给你换过尿布。而我母亲说，我们之间的一切都不会改变。但我们花了一些时间来思考——你会怎么想？
Mrs. Miller has, for 43 years, been longing to see the child she'd given birth to. So she's excited about it. And my mother's like, what happened to my life? It exploded.
米勒太太43年来一直渴望见到她亲生的孩子，所以她对此很兴奋。而我母亲的态度则是，我的人生发生了什么？它彻底崩塌了。
Once things calmed down, Sue came to two conclusions. One, she wasn't going to become estranged from her mother. And two, it was her brother she might lose.
事情平息后，苏得出了两个结论。第一，她不会与抚养她的母亲疏远。第二，她可能会失去的是她的兄弟。
My name is Bob McDonald. And I am 61 years old. I would say that Sue and I were probably not that close for whatever reason.
我叫鲍勃·麦克唐纳，今年61岁。我会说，不知为何，苏和我的关系可能没那么亲密。
The reason was pretty simple, actually. They have almost nothing in common. Bob is four and 1/2 years older than Sue, a sweet, jovial guy, who never got along with his broody little sister. And when Bob found out about Marti, found out that she was his biological sister, he called her right away in California.
原因其实很简单。他们几乎没有什么共同点。鲍勃比苏大四岁半，是个甜美、风趣的家伙，一直和那个忧郁的小妹妹合不来。当鲍勃发现马蒂的存在，并知道她是自己的亲妹妹时，他立刻给在加州的她打了电话。
When she got on the phone, I was just totally blown away. The way she pronounced her words were identical with the way my mother talked. She could have been my aunt or my mother talking on the phone. And I knew that she had to be my sister.
当她接起电话时，我完全被震撼了。她发音的方式和我母亲说话的方式一模一样。在电话那头说话的，听起来简直就是我的阿姨或者我的母亲。我知道她一定是我妹妹。
And I was super anxious to meet her in person. And until that time, we just talked all the time. With every phone call that we made, we opened up more to each other. And we had the same personality. And we think so much alike.
我超级渴望亲自见到她。在那之前，我们一直在通话。每次电话交谈，我们都更加向对方敞开心扉。我们有相同的个性，我们的思维方式也非常相似。
My brother and Marti are just thick as thieves, you know, it seems like. And whenever Marti comes to my hometown, she stays with my brother. And they stay up till all hours of the night talking.
我哥哥和马蒂简直亲如兄妹，你知道，看起来就是这样。每当马蒂回到我家乡时，她都住在哥哥那里，他们会聊到深夜。
For Sue, her brother's enthusiasm for Marti brought out every insecurity she suffered as a schoolgirl. She didn't fit in. She didn't have the social ease that came so naturally to Bob and Marti.
对苏来说，哥哥对马蒂的热情激起了她学生时代所有的自卑感。她觉得自己融入不了群体，没有鲍勃和马蒂那样自然的社交能力。
He was popular and I wasn't. I was a serious person. Nobody would dance with me at the dances. He had a band. I was shy or I was whatever.
他很受欢迎，我不是。我是个严肃的人。跳舞的时候没人邀请我。他组建了一个乐队，而我害羞，或者说不管怎么着吧。
And I wanted to be a cheerleader. I tried out for cheerleading. I just couldn't do it. I didn't get picked.
我曾想成为一名啦啦队长，尝试过竞选，但我做不到。我没有被选上。
As years went by, when there were family events with everyone, Sue would get anxious if Marti was there too. Occasionally, she'd break down and cry.
岁月流逝，每当有大家庭聚会时，如果马蒂也在，苏就会感到焦虑。偶尔，她会崩溃大哭。
I remember at the wedding when my nephew got married, my brother danced with everybody. He danced with Marti. And you can see, they're just having so much fun and laughing together and just dancing away. And then he danced with my cousin. He danced with my mother. He danced with everyone. He didn't dance with me. And here I am, you know, it's like I'm a teenager again and nobody dances with me. It was bad.
我记得在侄子结婚的婚礼上，哥哥和每个人跳舞。他邀请了马蒂。你可以看到，他们玩得非常开心，一起大笑，跳个不停。接着他又邀请了表妹跳舞，又邀请了母亲。他邀请了所有人，唯独没有邀请我。当时我就在那儿，感觉自己又回到了青少年时期，没人邀请我跳舞。那感觉太糟了。
But the good part about that was when I got home from the wedding, and my brother called me, and he said, you know what? I didn't even dance with you. And I said, who told you to say that? So he did know it too. But it just brought up feelings that you feel crummy again. And, you know, because I wonder what's going to happen when my parents are gone. Is my brother going to care to even see me anymore?
但好在婚礼结束后，我哥哥打来电话说，你知道吗？我甚至没和你跳舞。我说，谁让你说这个的？所以他确实也知道。但那种感觉又让你觉得很糟糕。你知道，因为我担心当父母不在了，哥哥还会愿意来看我吗？
This brings us to Marti, the other baby in this baby switch. Before she found out the truth about who her mother really was, Marti's life wasn't all that different from Sue's. Marti was also married, also had three kids. She'd also moved out of Wisconsin-- in her case, to Southern California. She's also religious like Sue. But that's pretty much where it ends.
这就带出了另一个孩子——马蒂。在得知亲生母亲是谁之前，马蒂的生活和苏并没有太大不同。马蒂也结了婚，有三个孩子。她也离开了威斯康星州——在她的情况下，是去了南加州。她和苏一样有宗教信仰，但除此之外就没多少相似之处了。
Marti worked all of her adult life, and still does, as a nurse. She grew up as the sixth child in a family of seven kids. Besides her, there was Mary Lydia, Faith, Ruth, Sonny, Luke, and Esther. Her mother ran a disciplined household. Everyone had to work. She remembers washing and drying all the dishes by the time she was five or six. There wasn't much money around. The five girls shared one bedroom.
马蒂成年后一直工作，直到现在还是个护士。她在七个孩子的家庭中排行第六。除了她，还有玛丽·莉迪亚、菲斯、露丝、桑尼、卢克和埃丝特。她母亲治家严谨，每个人都要干活。她记得五六岁时就要负责洗完并晾干所有碗碟。家里没什么钱。五个女孩共用一个卧室。
The church was the center of their lives. And the family never went on vacation or even to the movies. Instead, they were all taught to paint and encouraged to play music.
教会是他们生活的中心。全家人从不度假，甚至不去电影院。相反，他们都被教导画画，并被鼓励演奏乐器。
Like Sue, though, Marti stuck out in her family. For one thing, she was the only one who joked around. She says, even now, the Millers can't tell when she's being ironic. And then there was the blondeness and the perkiness and the socializing. Marti says she felt like everything she was interested in was lost on her parents.
然而，像苏一样，马蒂在家里也显得格格不入。首先，她是唯一一个爱开玩笑的人。她说，即使现在，米勒一家也听不出她什么时候是在自嘲。还有金色的头发、活泼的个性和善于社交的天性。马蒂说，她觉得她感兴趣的一切在父母眼里都一文不值。
I don't think that they ever came to watch me cheer in a game. That wasn't something that they would have done, because athletics was really not of value to them at all. I was just not ever meeting their expectation of intellectualism. And my mother has told me since then, you know, I really didn't expect that much from you, because I knew that you weren't our child. That was a hard thing to hear.
我觉得他们从来没来看过我的球赛啦啦队表演。那不是他们会做的事，因为体育对他们来说根本没有价值。我从未达到他们对知识分子那种期望。从那以后，我母亲告诉我说，我其实并没有对你有太多期望，因为我知道你不是我们的孩子。听到这个真的很难过。
Incredibly, when Marti was 21 years old, someone actually told her that she might not be a Miller. One of her older sisters, Ruth, came to visit with her husband Rudy. Rudy had a couple of beers. And after dinner, he got to talking.
令人难以置信的是，马蒂21岁时，有人竟然告诉她她可能不是米勒家的孩子。她的一个姐姐露丝带着丈夫鲁迪来探望。鲁迪喝了几杯啤酒，晚饭后就开始说话。
Then he started asking me what I knew about the McDonalds. And I really didn't know anything about the McDonalds. And then he told me that I looked like them. And he said, what would you do if I told you that they were your parents? And I was kind of stunned. It was the first I had ever heard anything about it.
他问我知道多少关于麦克唐纳家的事。我其实对麦克唐纳家一无所知。然后他告诉我说我长得像他们。他说，如果我告诉你他们才是你的父母，你会怎么做？我当时惊呆了。这是我第一次听说这种事。
And he did, in fact, say some hurtful things. Because he told me, well, I don't care what anybody says. As far as I'm concerned, you're not really Ruth's sister. I thought it was just Rudy being Rudy. He just has crazy ideas and he dreams these things up.
他确实说了些伤人的话。因为他告诉我，不管别人怎么说，就我而言，你根本不是露丝的亲姐妹。我以为这只是鲁迪在发酒疯。他总有些疯狂的想法，那是他编出来的。
And I was just horrified. And he didn't tell me ahead of time. He just came out with it.
我当时简直吓坏了。他没预先告诉我，而是直接脱口而出。
That's Ruth. She and Faith and Mary Lydia, the older girls, had sort of always known about the possibility that Marti wasn't their biological sister. A couple of them, including Ruth, had vague memories of their parents talking about it after they brought Marti home from the hospital, about how this baby looked different from Mrs. Miller's other babies, and that maybe this baby had been switched.
那是露丝。她、菲斯和玛丽·莉迪亚这些大一点的女孩，其实一直知道马蒂可能不是她们亲姐妹的事实。她们中的几个人，包括露丝，对父母把马蒂抱回家后谈论过这件事有模糊的记忆——谈论那个婴儿看起来和米勒太太其他的孩子不一样，也许抱错了。
Then when Ruth was about 16, her older sister Faith came home from a trip on a Mississippi River boat and told Ruth she'd seen Sue McDonald on the boat, and that she looked an awful lot like them. They decided that Ruth ought to have a look too. So the two girls cooked up a reconnaissance mission.
后来露丝大约16岁时，姐姐菲斯从密西西比河上的船上旅游回来，告诉露丝她在船上看到了苏·麦克唐纳，觉得她看起来非常像她们。她们决定露丝也应该去看看。于是这两个女孩策划了一次侦察任务。
On one Sunday, they got their boyfriends to drive them 17 miles away to the McDonald's church in Prairie du Chien. Ruth sat down in a Pew near the front next to Faith.
一个周日，她们让各自的男友开车带她们去了17英里外草原杜辛的麦克唐纳教堂。露丝坐在靠近前排的一个座位上，紧挨着菲斯。
Right before the service began, she says, there's Sue walking down the center aisle. And I thought, she even walks like Mary. I was just like, wow. Wow, that could be her. That could be my sister. And yeah, I think it might be.
仪式开始前，她说，看，苏正从中间通道走过来。我想，她连走路姿势都像玛丽。我当时想，哇。哇，那可能是她。那可能是我的姐妹。是的，我觉得有可能是。
And at any point during this time, does it cross your mind, well, why don't we just ask Mom and Dad about this?
在那段时间里，你有没有想过，好吧，为什么我们不直接问父母呢？
No.
没有。
That's not how their family worked. They just didn't talk about these kinds of things. And as Ruth and Faith saw it, it wasn't their place to mess in their parents' affairs, which is why, when her husband Rudy blurted it out a few years later, Ruth was so shocked.
他们的家庭不是这样运作的。他们就是不谈论这类事。露丝和菲斯认为，插手父母的事不关她们的事，这就是为什么当她的丈夫鲁迪几年后脱口而出时，露丝会那么震惊。
And Marti refused to believe it at that point. She denied it. And she says, oh, no, no, that's not true. So then I thought, well, OK, then it's not so bad. If she still believes she's my sister, that's good.
马蒂当时拒绝相信。她否认了，她说，噢，不，不，那不是真的。所以我当时想，好吧，那也没那么糟。如果她依然相信她是我的姐妹，那很好。
The next week, though, when Marti was visiting their mom, Mrs. Miller, she asked her about what Rudy had said. Mrs. Miller gave her a noncommittal answer, saying that once upon a time, they thought that maybe, perhaps, it might have. But even if it did happen, there was no way to prove it. So that was that.
然而，第二周当马蒂去探望母亲——米勒太太时，她询问了鲁迪说的话。米勒太太给了一个模棱两可的回答，说曾经确实有过这种猜测。但即使真有其事，也无法证实。事情就这样过去了。
Over the years, the thought that she might be someone else's child festered in the back of Marti's mind. And much later, when she was in her mid-30s, she decided to get to the bottom of it. She was working for a group of pediatricians, which included a genetic counselor. She told the counselor her story and said she wanted to get blood tests done. The counselor asked her what the McDonalds knew about all this.
多年来，她可能是别人家孩子的想法一直在马蒂脑海深处发酵。后来，在她30多岁时，她决定查个水落石出。当时她在一家儿科诊所工作，那里有一位遗传咨询师。她告诉了对方她的故事，说想做个血液检测。咨询师问她麦克唐纳家对这一切了解多少。
And I said, I don't think they know anything about it. So she said, well, if you were to find out that these parents that you have are not your parents and the other family doesn't want to have anything to do with you, how are you going to feel? And I said, well, I don't know. I don't have any idea.
我说，我想他们什么都不知道。她说，好吧，如果你发现你现在的父母不是你的父母，而另一家又不想跟你扯上关系，你会怎么想？我说，我不知道。我毫无头绪。
And she said, you really need to consider how that's going to change your family for you and how it's going to change relationships for you. So she said, unless there's a real reason that you need to know, she said, I don't recommend that you dig into it.
她说，你需要认真考虑这对你的家庭意味着什么，以及它会如何改变你的人际关系。除非有真正的理由需要知道，否则我不建议你深挖这件事。
That sort of spooked Marti, so she left it alone. And that's where it might have ended if it hadn't been for Mrs. Miller's letter a decade later.
那话把马蒂吓住了，所以她就没再管它。如果不是十年后米勒太太的那封信，事情可能也就到此为止了。
It's hard enough to learn that your mother isn't your mother, but it's even harder when that news is delivered by someone like Mrs. Miller. Tact isn't her strong suit. In fact, she seemed to have a tin ear for the whole thing.
得知自己的母亲不是母亲已经够难受的了，但如果这个消息是由米勒太太这样的人传达的，那就更难了。机敏并非她的强项。事实上，她对处理这件事似乎完全没感觉。
For starters, Mrs. Miller didn't contact Marti and Sue at the same time. She first sent the letter to Sue McDonald, the daughter she barely knew, and then waited almost two weeks before mailing the letter to Marti, the daughter she'd raised. She said she wanted to call Marti first, but never managed to reach her. As a result, Marti got worried about one of the most basic facts of her life secondhand, all the while waiting to hear directly from her mother.
首先，米勒太太并没有同时联系马蒂和苏。她先把信寄给了她几乎不认识的苏·麦克唐纳，然后等了近两周才寄给抚养长大的马蒂。她说她想先给马蒂打电话，但一直没打通。结果，马蒂通过他人的二手消息才得知了自己生活中最基本的事实，而且还是在等待母亲直接联系的情况下。
And in the meantime, I had gotten phone calls from people I didn't even know that we're telling me, hey, I'm your brother. Hey, I was switched at birth with you.
在此期间，我接到了一些我根本不认识的人打来的电话，他们对我说，嘿，我是你的兄弟。嘿，我出生时和你调换了。
When she finally heard from Mrs. Miller, the mother she'd grown up with, not only did she get the letter, but Mrs. Miller had just been to the 50th anniversary party of the McDonalds, Marti's biological parents.
当她最终从米勒太太——她从小抚养长大的母亲——那里得到消息时，她不仅收到了信，米勒太太还刚参加了麦克唐纳夫妇——马蒂的亲生父母——的50周年纪念派对。
And so she took one of the programs from it and she mailed it to me. And basically-- and this is going to sound like kind of a small thing, but it was a big thing to me-- she circled the names of people that were participating in the program. Like one of my uncles on the birth side, Earl Gonzalez, she circled his name, and she wrote, this is your uncle. And she circled my brother's name and said, this is your brother. Like Bob and Kay, she would circle their names and say, these are your parents.
于是她拿了其中一份流程单寄给我。基本上——这听起来可能是件小事，但对我来说是一件大事——她把参加仪式的人的名字圈了出来。比如我的亲生家庭里的一个叔叔，厄尔·冈萨雷斯，她圈了他的名字，写道，这是你的叔叔。她圈了我哥哥的名字说，这是你的兄弟。像鲍勃和凯，她会圈出他们的名字说，这是你的父母。
And I'm reading this thing going, what do you mean this is my uncle, this is my brother, this is my mom and dad? This is not my family. I don't even know who they are. And I took that as, OK, I'm saying as of right now, you're not our kid. You're their kid. You're in their family.
我读着这些东西，心想，你这是什么意思？这是我的叔叔，这是我的兄弟，这是我的爸妈？这不是我的家庭。我连他们是谁都不知道。我把这看作是，好吧，我现在就明说，你不是我们的孩子。你是他们的孩子。你是他们家的人。
Marti says her mom, Mrs. Miller, sees the world in black and white. She focused on the facts of the situation, maybe hoping she could fix things by simply setting the record straight. She wasn't malicious. She wasn't trying to be hurtful. After all those years, she was just tired of secrets. And now she wanted everyone's role to be clear. But it was hard, Marti says, to be on the receiving end of this sudden adamant truth-telling.
马蒂说她的母亲——米勒太太——眼里的世界是非黑即白的。她专注于情况的事实，也许希望通过简单地摆明真相来解决问题。她并没有恶意。她不是想伤人。多年以后，她只是厌倦了秘密。现在她想让每个人的角色都明确。但马蒂说，作为这种突然而固执的真相告知的接收方，真的很艰难。
There were a few years there, where every chance my mother got, she made it perfectly clear that I was a McDonald. For the longest time, whenever she would write to me, she would include McDonald in my name.
有几年时间，每有机会，我母亲都会明确表示我是一个麦克唐纳。很长一段时间里，每当她给我写信，她都会在我的名字后面加上“麦克唐纳”。
Oh, my god. Are you serious?
噢，天哪。你是认真的吗？
Just absolutely bizarre things like that. That's just how she is. There is no gray area.
绝对是那种极其怪异的事情。她就是这样的人。没有灰色地带。
Actually, my mother wanted to go to court and have my name legally changed back to Sue McDonald and have Sue's name changed. That was her idea.
事实上，我母亲当时想去法院，把我的名字合法改回苏·麦克唐纳，并把苏的名字改过来。那是她的主意。
She tells me that you're my daughter. But at the same time, when she refers to Kay, she says, well, your mother is doing such and such or your mother said this. And when I think of my mother, I think of her.
她跟我说你是我女儿。但同时，当她提到凯时，她说，噢，你的母亲正在做某事，或者你的母亲说了这个。当我想到母亲时，我想的是她（米勒太太）。
During this time, it was Marti's dad, Reverend Miller, who reassured her. They started talking on the phone a lot. He explained things like why all those years ago, he refused to return to the hospital and switch back the babies. And he let Marti know that he still loved her.
在这段时间里，是马蒂的父亲——诺伯特牧师——给了她慰藉。他们开始经常在电话里交谈。他解释了为什么多年前他拒绝回到医院换回婴儿的原因。他让马蒂知道他依然爱她。
He did not want her to push me out of the family. He, in fact would call me and tell me, I don't care what she says, you're still our kid and I'm glad we had you.
他不希望她把我赶出家庭。事实上，他会给我打电话说，不管她说什么，你依然是我们的孩子，我很高兴我们拥有你。
Did you feel that then after this happened a little bit closer to your dad than your mom?
事情发生后，你是否觉得和你父亲比和母亲亲近一点？
Yes. Yes, definitely, at that point. My dad had this horrendous guilt, because he felt like it was all his fault that he should have believed my mother for all those years. And I think he honestly never thought it was a possibility. He thought she really dreamed this up in her head and just got obsessed with it.
是的，是的，那一刻绝对是。我父亲感到巨大的内疚，因为他觉得那是他的错，他多年前应该相信我母亲的话。我想他真诚地从未认为那是可能的。他以为她真的是在脑子里编造了这些，并对此着了魔。
And the other thing was that he really thought, what difference does it make? A child is a child. She's with us. She's ours now.
另一件事是，他真的认为，这有什么区别吗？孩子就是孩子。她和我们在一起。她现在就是我们的了。
The other problem for Marti was how to approach the McDonalds, her biological parents. They were nice enough when she spoke to them on the phone, but they weren't exactly welcoming her into the family.
马蒂面临的另一个问题是如何接近麦克唐纳夫妇，也就是她的亲生父母。他们在电话里说话时足够客气，但他们并不是真心欢迎她进入家庭。
I remember talking to Mother about, you know, this is your blood daughter.
我记得曾和母亲谈过，我说，你知道，这是你的亲生女儿。
Here's Bob McDonald, who, remember, was having these great phone calls with his newfound sister?
这是鲍勃·麦克唐纳，还记得吗？他一直在和这位新发现的姐妹愉快地通电话。
This is the daughter that actually was in you. And I mean, I understand you didn't raise her, but she is your blood, biological daughter. And I don't know that she was as excited about it as I was. And I couldn't figure that out at the time. She was guarded.
这是你亲生的女儿。我的意思是，我明白你没有养育她，但她确实是你的亲生骨肉。我不认为她像我一样为此感到兴奋。我当时想不通。她很提防。
They were nice enough when she spoke to them on the phone, but they weren't exactly welcoming her into the family.
他们在电话里说话时还算客气，但并不是真的欢迎她进入家庭。
From Marti's perspective, the genetic counselor's prediction from years before seemed to be coming true, and it felt like she was losing both her mothers. Marti wrote a letter to Kay and Bob McDonald, her biological parents.
从马蒂的角度来看，那位遗传咨询师多年前的预言似乎正在成真，她感觉自己快要失去两位母亲了。马蒂给她的亲生父母凯和鲍勃·麦克唐纳写了一封信。
"I want you to know that I will accept whatever contact you choose to have with me, even if it's none at all. I promise you, I'll never try to make you think of me as your daughter. I know that Sue's your daughter and no one could ever expect you to feel otherwise."
“我想让你们知道，无论你们选择与我有怎样的接触，我都会接受，即使完全没有联系也行。我向你们保证，我绝不会试图让你们把我当成你们的女儿。我知道苏是你们的女儿，没有人会期待你们有别的感觉。”
Marti eventually decided that the only way she was going to resolve this was by getting on a plane and flying out to Wisconsin to meet the McDonalds face to face and give them a real chance to get to know her. The get-together at Bob and Kay McDonald's house didn't go exactly as she wanted.
马蒂最终决定，解决这个问题的唯一方法就是坐飞机去威斯康星州，与麦克唐纳夫妇面对面，给他们一个真正了解她的机会。在鲍勃和凯·麦克唐纳家里的聚会并没有完全按照她的意愿进行。
From the McDonalds' perspective, Marti looked and acted remarkably like a McDonald. She got along famously with their son Bob. She even had the exact same oil painting hanging on her wall in California as they had in their living room, a landscape with trees and water. But Sue was the girl they'd brought up and they felt loyal to her, protective.
在麦克唐纳夫妇看来，马蒂在长相和举止上确实非常像个麦克唐纳。她和他们的儿子鲍勃相处得极好。她甚至在加州的墙上挂着和他们起居室里一模一样的油画，一幅有树木和水的风景画。但苏是他们抚养长大的女孩，他们对她感到忠诚、有保护欲。
I kind of felt like Bob and Kay were kind of keeping me at an arm's distance, because they weren't really sure how they felt or wanted to feel. And I don't think sue had that sense.
我感觉鲍勃和凯把我拒之门外，因为他们不确定自己的感受，也不确定自己想怎么感受。我不认为苏有这种感觉。
In fact, that's true. Maybe because some of the Miller girls had suspected that she was their sister for decades and because Mrs. Miller always knew the truth, Sue was being embraced completely by the Miller clan. And so while Sue had feared everyone would choose Marti, the outgoing cheerleader, over her, it didn't work out that way. Here's Marti.
事实上，这是真的。也许是因为米勒家的女孩们几十年来一直怀疑她是姐妹，而且米勒太太一直知道真相，所以苏受到了米勒家族的全力拥护。所以当苏担心每个人都会选择外向的拉拉队长马蒂而抛弃她时，结果却并非如此。这是马蒂说的话。
In fact, it was the exact opposite. She had both families wanting to make sure that she was included in their family. The Millers wanted to incorporate her family into our family as quickly as they could. I did feel in the beginning like she was taking my place in my family. And that was odd, very odd.
事实上，恰恰相反。两家人都想确保她被纳入家庭。米勒一家想尽快把她的家庭并入我们的家庭。我一开始确实觉得她正在取代我在家庭中的位置。那感觉很奇怪，非常奇怪。
And sometimes I don't know exactly what her relationship is with my sisters. I honestly don't know how much they communicate, how much they're in touch. Part of me really doesn't want to know, because I think I would feel left out of something.
有时我不清楚她和我姐妹们的关系究竟如何。老实说，我不知道她们沟通多少，联系有多密切。我内心的一部分真的不想知道，因为我想我会感到被排除在某事之外。
Coming up, what it's like to be a mom and to learn at the age of 69 that your only daughter isn't actually your daughter at all, and, if that weren't bad enough, that lots of people in your town, people around you, knew years before you did. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，作为一名69岁的母亲，当得知自己唯一的女儿其实根本不是亲生女儿时，会是什么感觉？如果这还不够糟糕，那就是在你镇上，在你身边的人里，有许多人在你之前很久就已经知道了。一分钟后，《美国生活》节目继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
"This American Life." I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in, Jake Halpern is telling the story this hour of two girls switched at birth. One mother, Mary Miller, knew and kept it a secret, did nothing about it, for 43 years. The other mother, Kay McDonald, had no idea.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你刚收听节目，杰克·哈珀正在讲述两个女孩出生时被调换的故事。一位母亲，玛丽·米勒，当时就知道了，守口如瓶，整整43年什么也没做。另一位母亲，凯·麦克唐纳，则完全不知情。
The two fathers in this story were not interviewed. Mr. McDonald's health didn't allow it. Mr. Miller died in 2000. And so in this half of the story, we hear from the mothers. Again, here's Jake Halpern.
故事中的两位父亲没有接受采访。麦克唐纳先生的健康状况不允许。米勒先生于2000年去世。所以在这个故事的下半部分，我们听听母亲们怎么说。再次有请杰克·哈珀。
At the hospital in 1951, Kay McDonald was told that she'd given birth to a nine-pound, four-ounce baby. She didn't question that. Every day she was at the hospital, the nurses brought her the same baby girl. Nothing seemed amiss to her. And as that baby, Sue, grew up, the one thing that puzzled Kay was that Mrs. Miller, whom she knew only vaguely from church, seemed so interested in Sue.
1951年在医院里，凯·麦克唐纳被告知她生了一个九磅四盎司的婴儿。她没怀疑。她在医院的每一天，护士带来的都是同一个女婴。她没觉得有什么不对劲。随着那个孩子苏的长大，让凯困惑的一件事是，她只在教堂模糊认识的米勒太太对苏表现得太感兴趣了。
She always referred to the girls as sisters. After they were born, she had written us a Christmas letter and said she'd always liked to keep in touch with Susan, because the girls were so much like sisters. And of course, I thought that was foolish. But I went along with it, because I don't like to make waves, I guess, you might say. And so that's why I started sending them a copy of our Christmas letter.
她总是把这两个女孩称为姐妹。她们出生后，她写了圣诞贺信给我们，说她一直喜欢和苏保持联系，因为这两个女孩长得简直像亲姐妹。当然，我觉得那是胡闹。但我还是顺从了，因为我想，我大概不喜欢惹麻烦吧。所以我就开始给她们寄我们的圣诞贺信。
That's how Mrs. Miller kept track of Sue. Over the years, Mrs. Miller would do or say things concerning the girls, things that just seemed strange to Kay. When Kay's church was celebrating its 150th anniversary, for instance, Kay was chairperson for the event. Reverend Miller had once been pastor there, so he and Mrs. Miller were invited.
这就是米勒太太追踪苏的方式。多年来，米勒太太关于这两个女孩的行为举止，总让凯觉得奇怪。例如，当凯所在的教堂庆祝150周年纪念时，凯是活动的负责人。诺伯特牧师以前曾在那儿担任牧师，所以他和米勒太太受邀参加。
And the Millers came. And I was in the hallway. And Mrs. Miller said to me, did you ever think that our girls were switched at birth? And I said, heavens, no. I thought that was such a ridiculous thing to say. And of course, I was very busy, because I was chairperson and I had so many other things to do. So I passed it off. But that's all she said. There was nothing any further.
米勒夫妇来了。我在走廊里，米勒太太对我说，你有没有想过我们的女孩在出生时被调换了？我说，天哪，没有。我觉得那简直是无稽之谈。当然，我当时很忙，因为我是负责人，有很多事要做。所以我没把这当回事。她就说了那一句话。再也没有后续。
It didn't bother me, because I couldn't see any merit to it. I didn't have a doubt in my mind. And I'm not one to borrow trouble.
这没困扰我，因为我觉得这毫无根据。我心中毫无疑问。而且我也不是那种自寻烦恼的人。
What Kay McDonald didn't know was that there was a whole slew of people in her church community who had heard about the rumored baby switch from the beginning. Mrs. Miller and Kay McDonald were actually in different churches. Kay was a Methodist and the Millers were Evangelicals.
凯·麦克唐纳不知道的是，她的教会群体中有大批人从一开始就听说了那个关于调换婴儿的谣言。米勒太太和凯·麦克唐纳实际上不在同一个教堂。凯是卫理公会教徒，米勒一家是福音派教徒。
Mrs. Miller told people in the Evangelical Church that her suspicions, friends of hers and people she hoped would keep an eye out on Sue. But later, the two churches merged. So a bunch of people from the Evangelical Church now knew who Kay McDonald was and who Sue was, and realized that this was the girl Mrs. Miller believed to be her own. And this whole crop of people knew, but never said anything to Kay McDonald. One of them was Darlene Wolfgram. She heard it first from her own mom, who heard it at church.
米勒太太把她的怀疑告诉了福音派教堂的人、她的朋友，以及她希望多关照苏的人。但后来两个教堂合并了。所以福音派教堂的一群人现在知道谁是凯·麦克唐纳，谁是苏，并且意识到这就是米勒太太认为属于她自己的孩子。这一群人都知道，但从没告诉过凯·麦克唐纳。其中一个叫达琳·沃尔夫格拉姆。她是先从她母亲那听说的，她母亲是在教堂听说的。
She said everybody at church, after having seen Marti beside the rest of the family, just couldn't believe that that was their child. It was pretty concealed right within our own church. Probably the Ladies Aid, maybe, you know, the little group that got together. In fact, my mother said, well, just don't tell anybody. So we never said anything about it.
她说教堂里的每个人，在看到马蒂站在那家人身边后，都无法相信那是他们的孩子。那秘密就埋在我们自己的教堂里。大概是“女士互助会”之类的小团体里。事实上，我母亲说，嗯，只是不要告诉任何人。所以我们从未提起。
Darlene Wolfgram did tell her daughter, though. And the daughter, bear with me, ended up marrying Sue's brother Bob. But even she never divulged the secret to Bob or any of the McDonalds. Here she is. Her name's also Sue.
不过达琳·沃尔夫格拉姆确实告诉了她的女儿。这个女儿，耐心点，最终嫁给了苏的兄弟鲍勃。但即使是她，也从未向鲍勃或任何麦克唐纳家人泄露过这个秘密。就是她。她的名字也叫苏。
No, I didn't. Because it was always just a rumor. And I thought, well, he'll think I'm nuts.
没有，我没说。因为那始终只是谣言。我想，好吧，他会以为我疯了。
And he was very angry at first with me. And he said, why wouldn't you have told me that? And I said, would you have believed me? I mean, I'd say, gee, guess what, Bob? I don't think your sister's yours.
起初他对我非常愤怒。他说，你为什么不告诉我？我说，你会相信我吗？我的意思是，我说，嘿，猜猜看，鲍勃？我不觉得你妹妹是你的亲妹妹。
Well, there was no DNA testing back then or anything else. So there would have been no proof.
嗯，那时候没有DNA测试，什么都没有。所以根本不可能有证据。
That's what most people in town seemed to feel. It wasn't their place to bring up such a thing, especially with no way to know if it was true for sure, What that meant was that after Kay McDonald finally found out the truth in 1994, people started coming up to her, in church mostly, casually mentioning that they'd known about it all along.
这似乎是镇上大多数人的想法。插手这样的事并不是他们的责任，尤其是在无法确定真假的情况下。这意味着，在凯·麦克唐纳终于在1994年得知真相后，人们开始走到她面前，大多是在教堂里，随便提到他们一直都知道这件事。
I was surprised that nobody really ever told us, the Booms, the Tinors, the Langs, the Haisens. I just couldn't believe it. I just thought it was odd that so many people would know in a town of our size, which is like 5,500 people, when that many people were aware of it, that the news didn't get to us.
我很惊讶竟然没有人真的告诉我们，布姆家、蒂诺家、朗家、海森家。我简直不敢相信。我只是觉得奇怪，在一个像我们这样约5500人的小镇里，有那么多人知道，这个消息竟然没有传到我们耳朵里。
Slowly, anger began to set in. Kay was angry that Mrs. Miller hadn't corrected things back in 1951, that Mrs. Miller had hijacked her life in this way. And she was angry that Mrs. Miller put Sue in the difficult position of having to break news like this to her parents. And angry that now the Millers were asking so much of Sue's time and attention. It got so bad, Kay had to go on medication for high blood pressure.
慢慢地，愤怒涌上心头。凯愤怒米勒太太没有在1951年就把事情纠正，米勒太太以这种方式绑架了她的人生。她也愤怒米勒太太把苏置于一个尴尬的境地，不得不向父母说出这样的消息。她还愤怒米勒一家现在要求苏花费太多的时间和关注。事情变得很糟，凯不得不开始服用高血压药物。
Well, of course, they were really clamoring to get to know her. And I felt excluded. I felt they were trying to take her away from us. And Susan always had said to me, Mom, why didn't you have any more children after I was born? She wanted to be a part of a big family. So then she found out she has all of these brothers and sisters. And the phone calls were fewer.
嗯，当然，他们非常迫切地想要了解她。我感到被排除在外。我觉得他们想把她从我们身边抢走。苏一直对我说，妈妈，为什么在我出生后你没有再生孩子？她想成为一个大家庭的一员。然后她发现自己有这么多兄弟姐妹。于是（她和我们的）电话联系就少了。
And of course, Marti didn't really call a whole lot. She's a very busy gal and I was not having that much communication with her. And I thought I was losing both of them.
当然，马蒂也不怎么打电话。她是个大忙人，我和她沟通也不多。我以为她们两个都要离我而去了。
Kay McDonald began getting notes and phone calls from Reverend Miller. He told her that he thought it was God's will that this had happened. Even so, he asked her for forgiveness again and again.
凯·麦克唐纳开始收到诺伯特牧师的信和电话。他告诉她，他认为这一切发生是上帝的旨意。即便如此，他还是反复恳求她的原谅。
He's just outright-- he's just saying, can you forgive me, just like that on the telephone?
他就是直接——就在电话里说，你能原谅我吗，就像那样？
Yes, and quoting scriptures all the time for me to read to console me. Because I had said that I had shed a lot of tears. And I had probably all of the emotions that you have with a death in a family. I think I went into a kind of a depression about similar to what I did when my mother died. And so, of course, he was trying to get me to say that I had forgiven them.
是的，一直引用经文让我阅读来安慰我。因为我说过我流了很多眼泪。我可能有家庭成员去世时所有的那种情绪。我想我陷入了一种忧郁，类似于我母亲去世时的感觉。当然，他试图让我说我已经原谅了他们。
How did you feel when he said this was God's will? What was your reaction?
当他说这是上帝的旨意时，你有什么感觉？你的反应是什么？
I couldn't believe that Because I don't have that feeling about-- I don't think God punishes us in any way. I think what we do is pretty much our own doing. But he had everybody convinced, I think, that it was God's will.
我无法相信。因为我没有那种感觉——我不认为上帝会以任何方式惩罚我们。我认为我们所做的一切很大程度上都是我们自作自受。但他似乎让所有人都确信这是上帝的旨意。
But I had talked to several of our former pastors who knew about the situation and they assured me that this was not God's will. They said that was a cop-out.
但我曾与几位了解情况的前牧师交谈过，他们向我保证这不是上帝的旨意。他们说那是在推卸责任。
And so I don't think that was too well received when I mentioned that. I told Mrs. Miller I felt that it was God's will, when she realized that she might not have the right child, I think it was His will that she do something about it.
所以我提到这一点时，似乎不太受欢迎。我告诉米勒太太我觉得那是上帝的旨意，当她意识到自己可能没抱对孩子时，我想那是上帝的旨意，让她做些什么。
She wrote that in a letter to Mrs. Miller eight years after she learned the truth. That's how long it took her to sort out her feelings. Kay McDonald and the Millers eventually reached a kind of detente. Kay is no longer angry the way she was, but she says she'll never understand why Mrs. Miller stayed silent for all those years.
这是她在得知真相八年后写给米勒太太的信。她整理自己的情绪花了那么长的时间。凯·麦克唐纳和米勒一家最终达成了一种缓和。凯不再像过去那样愤怒，但她说她永远不会理解为什么米勒太太那么多年来始终保持沉默。
If I had as strong a feeling as she did that I had the wrong baby, I would have pursued it. I don't care whether my husband objected or not. I feel like I should have made a wrong into a right.
如果我像她一样有强烈的预感自己抱错了孩子，我一定会追究到底。无论我丈夫是否反对，我都不会在意。我觉得我应该把错误纠正过来。
I only had one daughter and she had five daughters. In fact, we weren't even sure we'd have another child. So of course, we were elated when I did get pregnant. And then to think that I didn't get to raise the one that I had wanted so much.
我只有一个女儿，而她有五个女儿。事实上，我们甚至不确定能否再有孩子。所以当我确实怀孕时，我们当然欣喜若狂。然后想到我竟然没能抚养那个我如此渴望的孩子，太难过了。
So I never will probably understand why. I've forgiven them, but that doesn't mean that I've forgotten. I can still wonder why and probably never will know why it didn't come up any sooner.
所以我可能永远无法理解原因。我已经原谅了他们，但这并不意味着我忘了。我仍然会纳闷，而且可能永远也不会知道为什么这件事没能早点被提出来。
Mary Miller is 96 now. She lives by herself in the country. Her house is filled with the remnants of her and Norbert's life together in the church. They were married for 60 years. There's a large statue of an angel in her sitting room, which she's planning to put on her own grave.
玛丽·米勒现在96岁了。她独自住在乡下。她的房子里充满了她和诺伯特在教会共同生活的遗迹。他们结婚了60年。她的起居室里有一尊巨大的天使雕像，她打算把它放在自己的墓前。
When I first talked to Mrs. Miller about what had happened when Mary was born, she told me pretty much the same story she told in her letter, how she knew as soon as she got home and weighed the baby that the nurses had made a mistake.
当我第一次和米勒太太谈起玛丽出生时发生的事时，她讲的故事和信里的大致相同，说她回到家一称重，就意识到护士弄错了。
Yes, I told Norbert, I think we have the wrong baby. And he said, well, I wouldn't disgrace the doctor by telling him he gave us the wrong baby. And he says, this is a nice little baby. We'll keep her.
是的，我告诉诺伯特，我觉得我们抱错了孩子。他说，噢，我不会让医生丢脸，去告诉他他给错了我们孩子。他说，这是一个可爱的婴儿。我们留着她吧。
When your husband said to you, this baby's cute, let's keep it, did you agree with him immediately or was there a little bit of arguing back and forth over what to do?
当你丈夫对你说，这孩子很可爱，我们留下她吧，你是立即同意了，还是为了该怎么做争论了一番？
No, we didn't argue about that. But I kept looking for her. And I was always asking anyone who might have seen her. In fact, when I would go down and have any touch with the McDonalds-- we got introduced to them-- I tried to talk to her about it. And she told somebody that I was crazy. I was a crazy woman who thought I had her girl.
不，我们没为此争论。但我一直在找她。我一直在询问任何可能见过她的人。事实上，当我走下去和麦克唐纳一家有接触时——我们被介绍了认识——我试着和她谈过这件事。她告诉别人我疯了。说我是一个疯女人，以为我抱走了她的女儿。
It was a little surreal to hear her talk about it in this way, laughing like that, especially after hearing Kay McDonald's side of things. But then Mrs. Miller told me more her side of this story.
听她那样谈论这件事，尤其是在听了凯·麦克唐纳的一面之词后，显得有点超现实，甚至还那样笑。但接着米勒太太告诉我更多关于她那一面的故事。
For one thing, she explained just how sick she was after they'd gone home with Marti in 1951. She was losing blood and having spasms. She thought she was going to die. She told me that she even started calling around trying to find someone who'd be a mother to her six children.
首先，她解释了1951年他们带着马蒂回家后她病得有多重。她在大出血，还出现了痉挛。她以为自己要死了。她告诉我，她甚至开始四处打电话，试图找到能代替她照顾那六个孩子的人。
The sickness, she said, lasted for six or seven months. By the time she was well, fixing the baby switch problem was that much harder. Even if she could somehow convince everyone it was true, what would happen if you suddenly took a six-month-old away from the only mother she knew?
她说，这种病持续了六七个月。等她康复时，解决抱错孩子的问题就更难了。即使她能以某种方式说服大家这是真的，如果你突然把一个六个月大的孩子从她唯一认识的母亲身边带走，会发生什么？
And the family's relationship with Dr. Deslack was no small thing either. Reverend Miller had made many visits to Dr. Deslack's wife when she was sick and now Dr. Deslack refused to charge the Millers for anything. The Millers didn't have much money and they might not have been able to afford the health care otherwise.
而且这家人和德斯拉克医生的关系也不小。诺伯特牧师在德斯拉克医生的妻子生病时多次去探望，现在德斯拉克医生拒绝收取米勒家任何费用。米勒家没什么钱，如果不这样，他们可能负担不起医疗费。
Well, of course, we felt indebted to him for doing that. This doctor had been so kind to us and good to us. And why ruin all that? That's a big consideration.
嗯，当然，我们觉得欠他人情。这个医生对我们那么好、那么仁慈。为什么要破坏这一切呢？这是一个很大的考虑因素。
Because Mrs. Miller didn't want cross her husband, all she could do was hope that maybe if she dropped enough hints, calling the girls sisters and such, Kay would eventually realize on her own what had happened. It was an odd strategy, if you can even call it that.
因为米勒太太不想违背她丈夫的意思，她所能做的就是希望通过旁敲侧击，比如称呼女孩为姐妹之类的，凯最终能自己意识到发生了什么。这是一种奇特的策略，如果这也算策略的话。
When Sue got married, for instance, the Millers gave her a trivet Norbert had made. The card was signed, from your other possible parents. Sue dismissed it as part of the whole sister thing, which she also thought was kind of weird.
比如在苏结婚时，米勒家送了她一个诺伯特做的三脚架。卡片上签着，“来自你们另一对可能的父母”。苏以为这又是那套姐妹把戏的一部分，她觉得这也挺怪的。
Mrs. Miller's most ambitious scheme happened after the girls graduated from high school, when they were about to be 18. Mrs. Miller arranged for the McDonalds to come to dinner. She figured if she could simply get Kay to look at Marti, Kay would figure things out. The evening just ended up being kind of baffling for everyone involved, since only Mrs. Miller knew what was going on.
米勒太太最宏大的计划发生在女孩们高中毕业，即将18岁时。米勒太太安排了麦克唐纳夫妇来吃晚餐。她心想，如果能让凯看看马蒂，凯就会想明白。那个晚上对所有参与的人来说都显得莫名其妙，因为只有米勒太太知道发生了什么。
But they didn't notice any-- I don't know why they didn't notice it that Martha looked like them and was like them. I don't know why they didn't notice that.
但他们没注意到任何——我不知道为什么他们没注意到马莎长得像他们，也像他们。我不知道为什么他们没注意到。
The fact is, Mrs. Miller longed for Sue, for her biological daughter, ever since she realized the mistake back in 1951. But it seemed futile trying to convince her husband Norbert.
事实是，米勒太太自1951年意识到错误以来，就一直渴望见到苏，见到她亲生的女儿。但试图说服丈夫诺伯特似乎徒劳无功。
I said, I think we-- it's not right to do that, to keep somebody else's baby. I didn't think it was right to do that. And every time I'd talk to him, he'd say, oh, it's all right. It'll be all right. And I can't tell you how hard it was, but it was hard on me all along.
我说，我想我们——留着别人的孩子是不对的。我觉得那样做不对。每次我和他谈，他都说，噢，没事。会没事的。我无法告诉你那是多难受，但这对我来说一直是个心结。
Were you afraid of Norbert at all?
你怕诺伯特吗？
Well, no, I wasn't afraid of him. I knew there were things that I couldn't do and keep his friendship, you know, if I turned against him, like on that.
嗯，不，我不怕他。我知道有些事如果我反对他，就无法维持我们的友谊，你知道的。
I guess you can't understand. I didn't want to have a disagreement like that with him, because that would have ruined our marriage. That would have ruined it. And I didn't want it ruined. I had six little children to take care of.
我想你可能无法理解。我不想和他发生那样的争执，因为那会毁了我们的婚姻。那会毁了它。我不想毁了它。我有六个小孩要照顾。
Was there ever a time when you thought back and thought, I should have stood my ground more with him on that?
有没有那么一刻你回想过去，觉得，我当初应该在这件事上对他更坚持一点？
No, I guess I haven't, because I knew it wouldn't have worked. I couldn't do anything about it. Norbert and I had a good time while we were together. But Norbert should have gone back and said, this isn't our baby. And this was a bad decision. But he didn't realize what affect that would have on everybody to make a decision like that.
不，我想没有，因为我知道那不会奏效。对此我无能为力。诺伯特和我在我们在一起的时候过得很愉快。但诺伯特本应回头说，这不是我们的孩子。那是一个糟糕的决定。但他没意识到做出那样的决定会对每个人产生什么影响。
Neither Sue nor Marti blames Mrs. Miller for going along with her husband. They say they're not angry with her. They knew Reverend Miller. They understand what their relationship was like. They understand why she didn't speak out sooner.
苏和马蒂都没有因为米勒太太顺从丈夫而责怪她。她们说她们并不生她的气。她们认识诺伯特牧师。她们理解那时的夫妻关系是什么样的。她们理解为什么她没能早点说出来。
42 years after the switch, Reverend Miller finally laid eyes on Sue at the McDonalds' wedding anniversary party. And the moment he saw her, he knew that she was his biological daughter. She looked exactly like him. At last, Mrs. Miller felt free to act. A month and a half later, she wrote the letter.
在调换42年后，诺伯特牧师终于在麦克唐纳夫妇的结婚纪念派对上见到了苏。那一刻他见到她，就知道她是他的亲生女儿。她长得和他一模一样。终于，米勒太太感到可以行动了。一个半月后，她写了那封信。
Yeah, I wanted him to agree with me. And he did. He finally did. But boy, it was a relief for me. Because that was terrible to have that hanging over you all of the time. It's sad that it happened. It took Kay an awful long time. And I'm sorry for her.
是的，我想让他同意我的观点。他同意了。他终于同意了。但天哪，那对我来说真是一种解脱。因为一直把那件事悬在头上真的太可怕了。发生这种事真可悲。凯花了很长时间（才接受）。我很为她感到难过。
One thing Mrs. Miller doesn't regret is raising Marti. She remembers Marti always lightening the mood in their house.
米勒太太不后悔的一件事是抚养了马蒂。她记得马蒂总是让家里的气氛变得轻松。
As a kid, she was really a live wire. She always had jokes. She had jokes every day. And she'd keep us laughing. It was good for us to laugh. It was really good for us to have her around. I mean, that my kids are all so serious about their life. They are more like I am.
小时候，她真的是个活宝。她总是讲笑话。她每天都有笑话。她让我们笑个不停。能笑出来对我们很有好处。家里有她在真好。我是说，我的孩子们对生活都那么严肃。她们更像我。
Before when I'd asked you if you thought it was God's will, you said yes. And is the reason because Marti brought something important to your family?
之前我问你是否认为这是上帝的旨意时，你说是。原因是因为马蒂给你们家庭带来了什么重要的东西吗？
Yes, she did. She brought happiness.
是的，她带来了。她带来了快乐。
"Dear Sue, I'm writing you this short note to officially give you my welcome to this Miller family and relationship."
“亲爱的苏，我写这封短信正式欢迎你加入米勒家族和我们之间的关系。”
This is Sue reading a letter she got some time ago from her newfound Miller sister, Faith.
这是苏在读她前段时间从新发现的米勒家姐妹菲斯那里收到的一封信。
"Though there are many, many good things about our family and parents and being raised by that family, there were also some definite deficits. If you're ever curious as to what they were, I would be very willing to fill you in, so you fully appreciate the parents who raised you. Between ourselves, Ruth and me, we, or at least I, always figured you lucked out. Probably Martha with her happy-go-lucky nature could take the climate of the Miller home better. And we hope you flourished in the McDonald household."
“虽然我们的家庭和父母有很多很多好的方面，被那个家庭抚养长大也很好，但同时也存在一些明显的不足。如果你好奇那些是什么，我非常愿意告诉你，好让你充分欣赏抚养你长大的父母。在我们自己人当中，露丝和我，我们——至少是我——一直觉得你很幸运。也许马莎那种随遇而安的天性更能承受米勒家庭的环境。我们希望你在麦克唐纳家庭茁壮成长。”
Wow. Wow.
哇。哇。
Yeah.
是的。
So she's basically saying to you, you may have actually gotten a break here being in the family that--
所以她基本上是在对你说，你可能实际上因为身处那个家庭而占了便宜——
Yeah, I lucked out.
是的，我很幸运。
Are there times when you feel a little bit guilty about kind of having lucked out with the home that was maybe a little bit easier to grow up in?
有没有那么些时候，你会因为觉得自己在成长环境上可能比较轻松而感到有点内疚？
Well, sure, I guess, a little built of guilt, but it's not my fault. I didn't have anything to do with it.
嗯，当然，我想有一点点内疚，但这不是我的错。那与我无关，我没法左右。
My sister Faith called. And she was talking about the way her mother would talk to her. And I'm thinking, how would I have survived with that kind of upbringing? And I didn't grow up like that at all. I don't know how I would have survived.
我姐妹菲斯打来电话，谈到她母亲跟她说话的方式。我在想，如果我在那种成长环境下，我该如何活下来？我根本不是那样长大的。我不知道我该怎么活下来。
But Sue says there are a lot of things she missed out on, too, by not growing up with the Millers. The family did all kinds of hobbies, painting and rock polishing and 3D photography. They had dogs and raised angora rabbits. All sorts of interesting people came to the house, guests from out of town and missionaries. It was a different way of living, one that she admires.
但苏说，她也因为没有在米勒家成长而错过了很多东西。那家人有很多爱好，绘画、磨石头、3D摄影。他们养狗，还养安哥拉兔。家里来了各种有趣的人，外地的客人和传教士。那是另一种生活方式，她很钦佩。
As for Marti, she doesn't like to dwell on the notion that Sue might have been the one who lucked out.
至于马蒂，她不喜欢纠结于苏可能才是那个幸运儿的想法。
Does the thought ever cross your mind, what if the switch hadn't been made? What if the McDonalds had just taken me home and I'd grown up in the house with my biological parents and my biological brother, who would I be?
你有没有想过，如果当初没有调换会怎样？如果麦克唐纳家带走的是我，我在我亲生父母和我亲生兄弟的家里长大，我会是谁？
Oh, that's a funny question. I really only thought about that one time. I only let myself think about it one time. It was actually right after I met them. And I was going back to my mother's house. So I left Prairie du Chien and I was driving. And it was then that I started thinking, oh, my gosh, my life would have been so different.
噢，那是道有趣的问题。我真的只这样想过一次。我只允许自己想过一次。那其实是在我见到他们之后不久。我当时正回我母亲家。我离开了草原杜辛，正在开车。就是那时我开始想，噢，天哪，我的人生本会如此不同。
And the more I thought about it, the more I realized, you know, I can't think about this, because it'll drive me crazy if I do. And so I kind of made a promise to myself that I would just never go down that road again, that I was just not going to go there. And I really haven't, because there's no point.
我越想越意识到，你知道，我不能再想了，因为如果我这样想会让我发疯。所以我对自己做了一个承诺，我永远不会再走那条路，我绝不会去想那件事。我真的没再想过，因为没意义。
It's pretty rare that Marti and Sue actually meet face to face. Once every few years, they get together for a large family gathering, a wedding, a graduation, a funeral.
马蒂和苏很少面对面聚在一起。每隔几年，她们会在一个大家庭聚会中碰头，比如婚礼、毕业典礼或葬礼。
This summer, Bob McDonald's younger son got married in Prairie du Chien. When Marti showed up at the house for brunch the day after the wedding, she couldn't have seemed more at home with the family that she didn't meet until her 40s. She teased the groom and handed Bob's older son a present for his baby.
今年夏天，鲍勃·麦克唐纳的小儿子在草原杜辛结婚。婚礼后的第二天，当马蒂出现在早午餐聚会上时，她在那家她直到40岁才遇到的人中间表现得再自在不过了。她逗弄着新郎，并递给鲍勃的大儿子一份礼物给他孩子。
It's a little late. It's for your child. It's before kindergarten, so it's OK.
有点晚了。这是给你孩子的。在上幼儿园之前，所以没关系。
He's 10 months old.
他才10个月大。
Shut up. Yeah, so it's a birthday present.
闭嘴。是的，所以这是一份生日礼物。
When Sue arrived, she slipped in quietly. This was the side of the family she was raised with, but she seemed tense, watching as Marti made the rounds, everybody laughing.
当苏到达时，她静静地溜了进来。这是她从小长大的家庭，但她显得很紧张，看着马蒂和大家打成一片，笑声不断。
Having the two of them so near each other was a little awkward. People were definitely aware whenever both women were in the same room. At one point toward the end of the party, as Sue stood nearby, Marti started talking about the room that she had grown up in in the Miller household. All the girls were in the same room. Marti shared a bed with her sister, Faith, and had to crawl through this vent to get to the bathroom at night, because Faith would block the doorway to the hall.
让她们俩靠得这么近确实有点尴尬。当两位女性出现在同一个房间时，人们肯定会注意到。在派对快结束时，苏站在旁边，马蒂开始谈论她在米勒家住过的那个房间。所有的女孩都在同一个房间里。马蒂和姐妹菲斯共用一张床，晚上还得爬过这个通风口去厕所，因为菲斯会挡住通往走廊的门口。
So instead of going in the hall and going out, we would crawl through the register.
所以与其去走廊走出去，我们只好爬过调节板。
Going the normal way, like most [INAUDIBLE]?
走常规路线，像大多数（人那样）？
Well, my sisters had this crazy thing going on when Faith was a teenager. She would push the dresser and the cedar chest against the door.
嗯，当菲斯是青少年时，我的姐妹们有点疯狂。她会把梳妆台和雪松木箱推到门边。
In the room you were in, you mean?
你是说在你所在的房间里？
That's Sue. It was the first time I'd seen them talk to each other.
那是苏。这是我第一次看到她们俩对话。
Yeah, in the room that we slept in.
是的，在我们睡觉的房间里。
So then you had to go through the register to get to the bathroom.
所以你就不得不穿过调节板去厕所。
To get to the bathroom, you had to go under the bed and crawl.
为了去厕所，你不得不钻到床下爬过去。
That's like a dog door.
那就像个狗洞。
Exactly. Yeah, it was like a dog door.
正是。是的，那就像个狗洞。
Just out of curiosity, what was your room like?
出于好奇，你的房间是什么样的？
Yeah, what was your room like? You had your own room, didn't you, all to yourself?
是啊，你的房间是什么样的？你有自己的房间，不是吗，全属于你自己的？
I had my own room. Yes, I did. And my own bed, too, everything.
我有我自己的房间。是的，确实。还有我自己的床，所有东西都是我的。
That's what I'm talking about. Yeah, whatever. It was a different life.
那就是我说的情况。是的，随便吧。那是另一种人生。
Mrs. Miller says she worries for Marti and Sue, about whether they'll ever truly get along. But there's no question, things have gotten better between the two girls and their moms. Kay McDonald is still tight with Sue, the daughter she raised, but she's also much closer with Marti. Kay and Marti both cried when Marti left the wedding for California.
米勒太太说她为马蒂和苏担心，担心她们是否能真正和睦相处。但毫无疑问，这两个女孩和她们的母亲之间的关系已经改善了。凯·麦克唐纳仍然和她抚养长大的女儿苏很亲近，但她也和马蒂亲近了许多。当马蒂离开婚礼去往加州时，凯和马蒂都哭了。
And things are good with Mrs. Miller too. Marti's accepted that despite some of the clumsy things that her mother said and did when she broke the news to her, she meant well. Marti calls Mrs. Miller once a week to check up on her, just like Sue does.
和米勒太太的关系也很好。马蒂接受了这一点：尽管母亲在告知真相时说了一些笨拙的话、做了一些笨拙的事，但她是好意的。马蒂每周给米勒太太打一次电话问候，就像苏做的那样。
Now that the big family questions are mostly worked out, one of the toughest things both Marti and Sue have to deal with is logistical. Having two sets of parents and two full sets of siblings and cousins is kind of a practical headache. There are birthdays and graduations and figuring out where to spend holidays.
现在家庭的大问题大多已经解决，马蒂和苏面临的最棘手的事情之一是物流问题。拥有两套父母、两套完整的兄弟姐妹和表亲，在实际生活中是个头疼的事。有生日、毕业典礼，还得考虑假日去哪儿过。
Earlier this month, Sue's daughter got married in Michigan. All the Millers were invited and all the McDonalds were too. Marti considered whether she should go. She didn't grow up with Sue, after all, and she's not actually related to her or to her kids. But in the end, she made the trip, because she's a Miller and so is Sue, and she's a McDonald and so is Sue.
本月早些时候，苏的女儿在密歇根州结婚。所有的米勒家人都受邀了，所有的麦克唐纳家人也都受邀了。马蒂考虑过是否应该去。毕竟，她不是和苏一起长大的，她实际上和苏或者她的孩子们没有亲缘关系。但最终，她还是出发了，因为她是米勒家的人，苏也是；她是麦克唐纳家的人，苏也是。
Jake Halpern. He's the creator of the new comic "Welcome to the New World-- The True Story of a Refugee Family from Syria," which runs weekly in the "New York Times."
杰克·哈珀。他是新漫画《欢迎来到新世界——一个叙利亚难民家庭的真实故事》的创作者，该漫画每周在《纽约时报》连载。
Since we first broadcast this story in 2008, the mom who knew about the baby switch at the time, Mary Kay Miller, has died. She was 98 years old.
自从我们在2008年首次广播这个故事以来，当时就知道抱错婴儿这件事的母亲——玛丽·凯·米勒——已经去世了，享年98岁。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Marie and myself. Our staff for today's show includes Alex Blumberg, Sarah Koenig, Seth Lind, Lisa Pollak, Robin Semien, Alissa Shipp, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer for this episode is Julie Snyder. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
嗯，我们今天的节目由简·玛丽和我共同制作。我们今天节目的工作人员包括亚历克斯·布隆伯格、莎拉·科尼格、塞斯·林德、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克和黛安·吴。这一集的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。音乐协助来自杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Thanks, especially, to the McDonald and Miller families for letting us into their homes and telling their stories.
特别感谢麦克唐纳和米勒家庭让我们进入他们的家中讲述他们的故事。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. "This American Life" is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, to run a big radio station was not always the dream job that he wanted. No, no, no. His heart was elsewhere.
我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》通过PRX公共广播交易中心传送到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，运营一个大型广播电台并不总是他想要的梦想工作。不，不，不。他的心在别处。
I tried out for cheerleading. I just couldn't do it. And I wanted to be a cheerleader. I didn't get picked.
我曾试着竞选啦啦队长。但我做不到。我曾想成为一名啦啦队长。我没被选上。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of "This American Life."
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。